time out time out time out you guys it
was just announced that kamal is the vp
it was just announced
the comments i'm like even more
energized now
okay so let's dive in
[Music]
hi everyone i am elaine welteroth
and i am so so excited
to have the honor of interviewing
someone today who is
very special um and among many things
she is the emmy nominated star and
executive producer of
little fires everywhere d kerry
washington
hi elaine i'm so happy you're doing this
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you
we are about to run a clip that carries
selected
and warning there's a spoiler alert here
so
um and for those of you who have seen it
you remember this will bring you back
into the drama of the show so let's roll
the clip
if you haven't seen it step aside now
right is your real
last name
warren was my brother's name
i had a fantastic
brother
but he died
and then my parents disowned me and
you were my everything
and um and then we came here
and it feels like all of that changed
so sweetheart i think that i gave bb
our money because i needed to prove that
keeping you with me was the right thing
to do
because sometimes i don't know i don't
i don't know if it was right i don't
know that if i had given you the choice
that you would have chosen
me
oh that scene makes me emotional
all over again why'd you have to do that
to us carrie
i didn't i didn't totally choose it i
let like
people on my team help me choose these
things because i have a hard time
watching myself um often i mean i i
have to as a producer i watch the edit i
i watch the cuts
but um but it's hard to go back and
revisit the work
especially when the work is so personal
like this show
i can only imagine i mean i have no
problem watching you on screen i
i have to say that i i thought that you
were
phenomenal in this a congratulations is
an order
four emmy nominations that is incredible
what a feat
what a dessert well-deserved feat um
i'm just so incredibly happy for you um
i'm a huge fan of yours always but this
show in particular
just took you to a place i've never seen
you
go um um so we got we got it we have so
much to talk about as it relates to
little fires everywhere
but um i think first
i think we have to acknowledge the
moment that we're living in
um we're obviously here for an extremely
celebratory
reason which is you it's celebrating
your your
your big nominations but we just got
some big news
and so excited to be able to share with
this moment with you but maybe you can
tell the people what
we just heard the breaking news that
just
um we just we just heard i just got a
text about kamala harris being the vp
pick so i was so happy to be able to
share that with you and
and the amazing crew that's filming this
um
the behind the scenes folks with it's
just such incredible
historic news to have a woman
vp running mate to have a black woman vp
running mate
um she's somebody that i have known for
a
long long time and she's
she's a very dear person and i'm
i'm happy for her but i'm really excited
for the vision of what this country
can be with the right kinds of
leadership and obviously
this is a turbulent season um for all of
us for so many different reasons
um this is for me this is good news um
uh
but you know we're living in the midst
of a double
maybe even triple pandemic um depending
how you look at it and i know
you know you're home on top of the
triple pandemic i mean
um with the racial unrest with the pen
with the actual chronovirus pandemic and
then we're in this
swirl of a historic election year um
which is taking us on an emotional
roller coaster ride every single day in
the news cycle and then on top of all of
that
you're homeschooling three children
um well working full-time and somehow
finding time to like meditate with all
of us on instagram so just
thank you and but but really how how are
you doing how are you coping
how are you grounding yourself through
this time oh it's so
um i mean just i love being able to to
talk to you elaine it's like i'm
i miss being able to share physical
space with people but when we can
at least like share digital space with
people that
that make us feel safe and like like
it's safe to open our hearts and
um share of ourselves it's such a treat
so
i love you i love seeing you um you know
i'm doing
like everybody i'm i'm like just it is
one moment at a time you know not even
one day at a time it's like one minute
at a time
and um i think i'm i'm
you know trying to navigate all the new
normals and trying to
um to
pace myself because they you know i
don't think this is gonna
change overnight and um there's a lot
there's just a lot
to be navigating right now so i really
feel like i'm
i'm trying to just like be present and
of service
in the places that i can in the ways
that i can
and um so i really appreciate you
taking the space and time to have this
conversation because i know we all have
a lot on our plates right now
um but i also really appreciate how much
i i appreciate how much you saw
in little fires everywhere you know
because we were we were telling
so much story we were covering so
much ground and um and i think the show
resonates with a lot of people in a lot
of different ways but i feel like
you met the show in many of its story
points like you were able to really
like see us and hear us in in a lot of
what we were saying
so i'm really grateful for for that
perspective and for audiences that
really like
met us where we were and and were
willing to wrap
your very generous arms around all of
the different stories about motherhood
all the different kinds of mothers all
the different kinds of daughters
all the different um navigations of
identity
and race and class and um there you know
there was just
there's a lot going on in our show and
i'm really proud of it and i'm really
grateful that you
got it it was hard not to get i think
that
it is really a testament to
you and rhys and the whole writing team
and the directors i mean the casting was
exquisite i mean
it was every up i mean
i have chills just talking about it and
for those who aren't totally familiar
i'll give a quick you know backdrop the
show little fires everywhere is
essentially a study of
two women elena richardson who is a
wealthy mother of four
played by reese witherspoon who we both
love so much
and she's magnificent in the show she's
magnificent it's to me the performance
of her career and i'm a huge reese
witherspoon fan
is it's like she blows it out of the
water
she takes this to a place honey i yeah
never
yeah see greece witherspoon go both of
you did um
so and then your character mia warren is
sort of this
nomadic single mom who sort of becomes
inextricably
linked to elena and her family
and there are so many unanswered
questions and secrets and mysteries that
sort of unravel
as the series unfolds and you know you
see
ultimately these four women um who find
themselves in a web
with each other and they're all sort of
in these different states of desperation
and they need each other and they're
also at odds with each other
and they're also sort of grappling with
this idea of relative suffering
you know this idea that you know there's
always suffering
um that's worse than the suffering your
experiences but
then what you're experiencing and so
it's just it's so layered it's so
complex
um and and like life it requires you
to see uh the good
and the bad the light and the dark um in
all of these characters and all of these
complicated relationships
um i mean i think what i loved the most
about the show
is that it isn't simply for mothers
or women um or young people while
there's a lot of young people in
in the series um but it's really for the
entire family and it's really for
anyone and and it lends itself to like
multi-generational
viewing interracial viewing and sparks
conversations between
kids and parents friends and spouses and
i know it because i was out here
sparking them after i watched the show
i'm curious from your perspective um you
know as a producer and as
one of the stars of the show and as
someone who had the
luxury now in this in this you know
generation of being able to
watch some of those electrifying
conversations play out in real time on
social media
what were some of the conversations that
you found the most moving or maybe that
you were
surprised by there were two
conversations that i thought were most
exciting for me
one was i really loved
a lot of the responses from black women
who were like i see myself right like
who who recognize the micro aggressions
coming from elena and the need to
like continue to move forward in a space
that does not feel like it welcomes or
understands you
um that that that idea and it wasn't
just from black women it was from like
all kinds of marginalized people who
were like oh i have been in that space
with that person who is putting their
foot in their mouth and they don't even
know it
and i have to smile and like tuck it
away and
and trek on and um and that was really
exciting because that was something that
we
worked really hard on in the development
of the show of like
what is mia what is going on for mia
internally in these moments and how do
we capture that on screen
but not in such an obvious way that
elena would feel
disoriented or you know like we didn't
we didn't we wanted it to be
um mia's experience and not necessarily
be telegraphed
um to elena but still be witnessed by
the audience
so that was really exciting and then a
lot of um
a lot of folks who i think were
you know entering into this debate about
what it means to be a mom and what it
means to be a good mom
um because i think the show really kind
of explodes the idea
of of that assumption of what makes a
good mom
and um and we're really forced to be
more
nuanced and sort of accept a different
kind of complexity around like however
you mom
if you're doing the best you can that's
good mothering like
it doesn't have to meet a standard it
doesn't have to meet a label it's like
everybody's doing the best they can with
the tools they have
and and um yeah so that was another
conversation that was really fun to
witness
so you play mia warren um and
she is this deeply complex
um some might even say unlikable
uh the series
um which is actually refreshing to see
i think um and i think we are starting
to see more
and more female characters um who are
being given
their permission or giving themselves
the permission in your case you were
one of the producers on this project to
just be unapologetically
flawed and beautiful and fragile
and strong and your character was all
that and so much more
um i'm curious your relationship
became with your character and how you
were able to get into that headspace of
playing a role that is just so layered
um so raw um and also
if you could speak to sort of the just
the importance of why you think
you know holly it's time that hollywood
embraces
stories with unlikable and air quote
unlikable women
at the center of these stories on screen
well one thing i want to say is
i just want to point out reese reese's
performance because
um i really do like
i thought it took such enormous courage
for her to
take on the kind of um
the embodiment of privilege that she
does
i just thought to to reveal
um and to contextualize
who that woman is how she becomes that
way
how it's expressed the inner life the
inner workings like so i was doing an
interview where somebody was like she's
like the prototypical
karen aaron
but what she does actually is she
humanizes the karen
right like she makes you not traffic in
the stereotype
of white women tears and white women
privilege but really
understand where and why and how and i
think it's such a beautifully
courageous performance and so um
just like ninja acting to to watch
and i was there you know watching it in
person
um and i think for both of us you know
we don't think about playing
unlikable women i of course know what
you mean because that's what how a lot
of people describe it
but we're just playing real people like
and i think
when we allow ourselves to tell
narrative
about women who are three-dimensional
and complex and who have good days and
bad days and who have flaws
and assets that what we're doing is
actually giving permission
to all of us real women to be all of
those things right like
if we traffic in perfect ideas of
female identity then we're perpetuating
the disease
of perfectionism being a woman is not
about
trying to be perfect it's about being
human and
and even when we have things we want to
fix and grow about ourselves
until we face them we can't grow
and so i think when we face them in
characters
um it allows us to witness ourselves to
witness who we
want to be or who we don't want to be
and and we get to
like deal with our own humanity and the
humanity of our sisters when we tell
narrative about complex women
oh so well said
so well said um to your point about
reese's uh portrayal of
elena it it it it absolutely
was like watching the archetype of karen
just
just walk through the world like a bull
in a china shop
and reese's performance of this
archetypal character of karen i think
was
even harder to watch in the context of
what's happening in the world in this
moment
um you know seeing amy cooper
uh you know embody privilege
in such a dangerous violent way uh
in on the news right and on our on our
phones and then to watch this character
as you say and become the embodiment of
privilege and
and do it and she played that character
so well
and you're right it does it did
absolutely humanize that character to an
extent but
i i don't want to take the focus off of
what you were able to do as well with
your character because we
we have seen so many tropes about black
women
um and being
strong and mean
and the struggle kind of defining them
and and in some ways when we meet your
character
we see some of that and then as we get
to know her more and more
we see those layers kind of we see
beneath those layers
and and so what was it like for you
to be able to speak truth and and
portray a more truthful image
yeah it's interesting i i feel like
there's a lot of um
a lot of mission into
you know the layers on the show because
even in that first episode when you when
you meet mia i could see on social media
how people were like she's so
mean she's so angry you know like this
angry black woman and
and yet within the same episode you see
this
delicate delicate love for her daughter
this like
vulnerable innocent precious love and
even
that dynamic even that dynamic of saying
like this woman who may
look to this woman who out in the world
may appear to be angry
you have no idea what's going on in her
home
you have no idea who she is off the
clock
um she's she's dealing with defenses out
in the world but there are
vulnerabilities in places that you
haven't earned
that you don't get to witness we're
going to let you witness that in this
moment
um so that also was so much fun
just to like remind people that we can't
we cannot judge a book by its cover
and who we are out in public with each
other
navigating each other may not always be
the core of who we truly are
if we're in a safe space
again so so well said um i want to talk
about the process of adapting
this book you know as a producer you
were part of making the decision um to
change
mia and pearl's race in doing so the
show's writers needed to ensure that
those characters stories were told
authentically
um and so i'm curious what that process
was was really like for you
you know can you talk about some of the
decisions and the choices that were made
and what your role was and some of that
as a producer
yeah you know it wasn't my idea actually
um because i got the call from reese
witherspoon and her producing partner
lauren neustadter
um they they thought of me for the role
so it was really their idea to make mia
black and therefore pearl
black but i have to say you know
you know there's been a point in my
career i remember you know
years ago like for example i was in the
first fantastic four
and they my character alicia masters had
traditionally been this sort of blonde
haired character in the comic books
um in mid-century and and and they
they were like taking this amazing
historical choice
the film was directed by a black
director and he was like i want to make
alicia masters black
amazing but it was a big superhero movie
it didn't
impact the narrative of the film we just
made
alicia masters black and so it was like
this sort of
this period of colorblindness where like
let's do open casting
other characters can be other colors and
it doesn't have to impact anything
that was what progress looked like at
one point
this process was entirely different as
you mentioned because
by making mia and pearl black
in a piece that is all about exploring
identity
and difference and community and trust
and prejudice and um by by
layering in a difference in race between
mia and elena
it added entirely new levels of
responsibility in the story that we were
telling
and how we were telling it and that i
mean i'm really grateful that everybody
on the team
our writers our directors our editors
that everybody got on board
with really wrestling with what it means
to add race to the mix for this
character and it really did it impacted
every step of how we told this story um
i'm
i'm so deeply grateful to liz tigolar
our showrunner because she was
so committed to always
diving into the complexity with us
whether it was about
um sexuality whether it was about race
whether it was about class whatever it
was
um but but it required a lot of
um a lot of massaging and
and sort of almost like excavating like
we had to
we were like archaeologists excavating
like what if races in this story
what what does the story become right
um and and really being open to that and
holding space for it and allowing for it
absolutely there was a lot that i think
the show was able to
accomplish and a lot of ground that it
was
able to successfully cover because
of not just that decision that was made
to change their race but the
thoughtfulness
with which that decision was executed um
and so again that is a testimony
to you my friend as a producer but you
look at a moment right you
you look at a moment for example like um
in the book elena asks mia
to be her housekeeper and between
now celeste ing the brilliant novelist
who wrote little fires everywhere she
always says
um that mia was sort of racially
ambiguous to her she
in her mind she was already dealing with
being other because of class but she
hadn't specified that she was a black
woman
when you ask a black woman to be your
maid
it's an entirely different conversation
and i remember
sitting with the writers and saying like
we have to figure this out
because mia is also an incredibly
prideful
woman so if elena just asks her to be a
maid like
that's that's a moment we have to
grapple with the complexity the
discomfort
maybe elena has to find other words
besides housekeeper that's how the whole
like
house manager house helper conversation
got started because because we had
you know we talked about it in the
writers room like guys we like we can't
just say housekeeper and mia say yes and
not talk about how
fraught that is for a black woman in the
90s to just
dip in and be somebody's housekeeper as
if it's 1790
not 1990 right you know right
um so i i would love to hear um
carrie you talk a little bit about your
journey
from playing olivia pope for seven years
who we loved
watching so much week after week to to
shifting your focus professionally to
becoming a producer and i'm curious to
hear what
you know what that journey has been like
for you and what what were the kinds of
stories that you were eager to tell
and why producing really started for me
halfway through scandal i made a film
called confirmation
for hbo where i played anita hill
that was the beginning of my producing
career
um and i kind of fell into it i just
wanted to
tell that story um but i wanted to make
sure that i had some authorship and how
the story was told
and could be you know really have a seat
at the proverbial table
in terms of making decisions on that
project and so
i became a producer and then i later
became a producer toward the end of
scandal
on scandal and um and really i got bit
by the bug it's really about providing
an opportunity for
other people to do what they do right
like you get to
create the container where all these
artists and artisans come in and
and they get to pursue excellence um
because you've given them the playground
to do it
and so i really love that i love being
like a
a team captain cheerleader coach type of
person
on set and sort of um helping all of us
move toward a shared vision and and it's
important to me to
not just tell stories that i love but
also to
to you know not just to make great work
but to also
feel good making it like to help create
environments that
feel safe and um safe for people to be
creative and to
to do great work you know what an
experience it must be to have kerry
washington be your
onset cheerleader and champion
um i mean clearly you're having a ton of
success as a producer
so again congratulations you've had such
a prolific
year i mean three okay so let's talk
about these
there's three of your projects this year
really center on issues of race between
little fires everywhere
american sun the fight um
and i'm i'd love to hear from you why it
was so important to you to tell
these stories in this moment both as an
executive producer and
as an actress to me what these projects
all center on is um
is family and community
and belonging and i think that
like those are themes that i return to
again and again i mean i think in a lot
of ways scandal was also about family
and community like finding your family
where you can
grappling with your family of origin um
because i think
that you know our ability
as human beings to to
value each other as family is going to
be
necessary for our survival as a race
like as a human race
to me american son even the title
is really about the fact that the child
in that play
jamal he is the child of this black
mother and a white father but by the end
of the play
most people who witness the play feel
like jamal belongs to them
regardless of what race they are he
becomes
all of our son and and we realized that
we must all take responsibility
for the children of this country of this
world i mean when in the fight when when
that family grits
gets reunited and that mom is hugging
her daughter that after they've been
separated at the border
like you just realized like we have to
protect each other's children each
other's families
um it's that that fanny lou hamer quote
you know and unless we are all free none
of us are free
um so i think that's the the theme that
i keep
returning to in my work is is sort of
like
um the the love of family and the need
for liberation
really well said i i have to tell you i
saw american son
on broadway and i was so
moved by it and you know as someone who
grew up in a household with a
black mother and a white father and a
mixed-race black brother
um i really identified with the ways in
which
the the project created an entry point
for a nuanced conversation about
police brutality and how it specifically
affects the black community
but but but this conversation was
an interracial conversation and it
required
um folks on different sides of racial
divides
to wrestle with and grapple with this
very
um unfortunately timely
issue i found a quote from you that i
really
uh that just really resonated with me
you said for my whole life
art and social change have been
impossible
to separate um and you talked about
being
12 and 13 years old you know doing hiv
aids education and advocacy work um
through an arts and education theater
company
you know here in new york um and i read
somewhere that
your mother even begged you to be a
lawyer because she wanted you to pursue
you know this work through through that
conventional path but
so much of the work that you're putting
into the world does have this
um social justice bent and it's in
it's significant in terms of starting
conversations and we know
of the importance of work that has the
power to change hearts and minds
and start conversations that can change
our culture um which eventually will
change policies so
as we wrap up i i just would love to
hear
kind of you know as we approach emmy
season um
you have again four emmy nominations
um which i'm just going to keep on
saying that because i'm so proud but
but it but but it's you know it's a
celebratory thing in a really grim
moment in our history and so i
would just love to hear sort of some
final thoughts from you
on what it means to be
you know kerry washington this black
woman that is revered by so many with
this
huge platform that you have um you know
what what is your message to your fans
your community
that supports you um as we as we head
into not just emmy season but also
a historic election season i really try
not to get pulled into a lot of the
um the drama or the
the indications of awards as
worth right like i think there's a
danger
in putting too much value in a
nomination
that the nomination means that you
matter right like we
matter inherently as human beings we
matter inherently as
artists there is so much work that
deserves to be acknowledged so i'm
deeply deeply grateful but i also try to
not get too
caught up in it um because
the reason why it's hard for me to
untangle
activism and art at times is because i'm
a woman
and i'm a black person so when i center
myself
in the work that is that's activism
because i'm asking i'm inviting you to
see me
as a woman i'm inviting you to see me as
a black person
and to not allow me to be marginalized
but to allow me whether it's one hour a
week on scandal
or an hour and a half in american sun
i'm i'm
asking you to let me or the character
that i'm playing
a black woman matter in your world
in your heart in your mind and that's
important
that invitation to receive my humanity
my full complex humanity as a black
woman
i know that that is radical for some
people that some people
don't have the opportunity to see us or
receive us or step into our shoes and
into our lives
and i know we also don't get enough
opportunity to see ourselves
and to witness our own stories as
mattering enough to be worthy of a
narrative
on stage on screen on your tablet
wherever
so um so i take what i do
seriously as an artist because um
because i'm centering not just myself
but i'm centering
black womanhood in the stories that i'm
telling
where i am at the center it's not about
me it's not about
my ego to me i don't i don't see those
nominations actually as saying like
wow carrie washington matters really how
i receive that is like
these black women mia kendra
they have mattered this year and that is
very meaningful to me it's very
emotional for me because
you know the whole say her name hashtag
was was invented because we weren't
seeing
we don't see the black women who lose
their lives
um to police violence we we don't say
those names
and so we need to say her name and and
by
saying mia and kendra and living with
mia and kendra and olivia
we wrap our heads around how much
black women matter and to me i think
it's a
it is it means that sandra bland matters
it means that korean games matters
it means that brianna taylor matters um
so
i you know i don't i don't want to make
it seem
like it's not marching it's not i'm not
kamala harris i'm not doing a lot of the
the heavy lifting but i think our
narratives are important when we claim
space for the for the lives of black
women and so i'm grateful
that there are so many nominations for
narratives around black women this year
whether it's tracy ellis ross octavia
bella regina king like
we are we are mattering and we're not
going away
um and we're going to continue to fight
for our stories to matter so that
you continue to fight for brianna taylor
to matter
can i just give you a round of that
was the most grounding way
to wrap this conversation up and to
contextualize
what this moment means what your work in
this moment means and what your
emmy nominations mean um and as a fellow
black woman as a fan of yours as a
friend um
i i am proud of you and i want you to
know that
these emmy nominations no matter how
they
pan out your work matters so much
to us and we see you
and you represent us so beautifully
and i'm i'm weirdly getting emotional
just because of the way that you
contextualize what what this moment what
it means to be us
in this moment and we um we have so much
more work to do but i just want you to
know your work matters
and to everyone watching thank you for
taking the time
um to participate in this conversation
and
and i just know that all of you watching
feel as proud of carrie as
i do um so carrie hope you feel that
love
um from your your your community of fans
and um your friends in the industry and
we just
we're just so proud to watch you um
shine
and we know you were gonna shine on
emmy's day even if you're
at home on your couch we'll be tuning in
and we'll be rooting for you soon how
much love to you
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you